since at least 213 bc book burnings have
been a reaction to the power of the
written word
when roasting paper in a giant circle
went out of style
at least in the intellectual sphere
we hope governments would take it upon
themselves
to ban books however when we talk about
book bannings today at least in the
western world
we are usually discussing a specific
choice made by individual schools
school districts and libraries made in
response to the moralistic outrage of
some group this while still hotly
contested
problematic and controversial is still
nothing in comparison to the ways books
have been
removed censored and outright destroyed
in the past along with their authors
so on that happy note let's explore how
the seemingly innocuous
book has survived centuries of
the ban hammer
let's do it
historically speaking there are usually
three
big reasons books are banned religion
morality and politics the three things
you do not discuss
in dinner back in the bce era entire
ideas
religions and political movements were
and could be
wiped out not with a mass tweet but with
book burnings
and sometimes if things were really
intense
people burnings as well it was really
real
one of the earliest documented examples
in north america
is the burning of aztec and mayan
manuscripts in the
1560s by catholic priests and the
conquistadors
in tutor england during the schism
between the church of england and the
roman catholic church
depending on which monarch was
arbitrarily
in power and what religion they followed
your choice of religious book could get
you murdered
it was not a good time this was done as
french writer and historian lucian
x paul strong explains in books on fire
because of the lawmakers of ancient
china and the nazis in
checklist levakia decided an educated
people
cannot be governed because the conquered
peoples must
change the history of their beliefs like
the aztecs
because only the illiterate can save the
world
a common theme of the millenarian
preachers of every era because the
nature of a great collection of
books is a threat to the new power
historians point to harriet beecher
stowe's uncle tom's cabin
as the first book in the united states
to
experience a ban on a national scale
many southern states flat out prohibited
the sale of the book
stating that it stoked the flames of
abolition
and uncle tom's cabinet is actually
considered one of the books that started
the civil war
which you know considering all the slave
narratives is
a hot take but whatever one place you
could kind of call the billboard hot 100
of banned books
is the index librium prohibitorium
or list of prohibited books this was a
list of books and other publications
deemed
heretical by the vatican if you were
catholic
you could not read this content
without permission from a priest or
a higher power this include romantic
texts
astronomy science and anything else the
church saw as
antithetical to their faith victor hugo
over it copernicus and galileo cancelled
russo you gotta go funny enough charles
darwin's on the origin of species
was not listed among the banned texts
in question things that make it go
maybe they liked it it was banned from
the library of trinity college cambridge
and in the united states kept out of
many schools
in tennessee the book and teachings of
evolution
were banned until as late as 1967.
in nazi germany the government burned
thousands of books written by jewish
authors
communists and anyone else considered
other
include were the works of albert
einstein sigmund freud
ernest hemingway helen keller lennon
jack london karl marx often sinclair
stalin and leon trotsky those are
political and religious reasons but
sometimes a book can get in trouble for
being too
risque oscar wilde's the picture of
dorian gray
is according to literary professor
nicholas frankel
one of the first novels in the english
language to explore the nature
of homoerotic and homosexual desire
charles whibley mentee of w.e henley
the english poet critic and editor who
fun fact was also the inspiration for
long john silver
reviewed dorian as such mr oscar wilde
has
again been writing stuff that were
better unwritten and while the picture
of dorian gray which he contributes to
limp and cuts is ingenious interesting
full of cleverness and plainly the work
of a man of letters
it is false art for its interest is
medical legal
it is false to human nature for its hero
is a devil
it is false to morality for it is not
made sufficiently
clear that the writer does not prefer a
course of unnatural
inequity to a life of cleanliness health
and sanity mr wild has brains and art
and style
but if you can write for none but
outlawed noblemen and perverted
telegraph
boys the sooner he takes to tailoring
or some other decent trade the better
for his own reputation
and the public morals just simple taylor
that's a star trek joke some people will
like it
and this is in response to the edited
version
that wells publishers made where
according to frankl they cut out 500
words from the original
type script without wile's permission
when wald was put on trial for his
homosexuality or
gross indecency officially as it was put
in 1895
his novel was used as evidence that led
to his conviction
this prudishness sadly did not just
exist for the posh victorians
in america we had anthony comstock an
anti-vice activist he sounds
fun comstock got congress to pass the
comstock
law on march 3rd 1873 which prohibited
the mailing of pornographic materials
his definition of the term was murky at
best
anatomy textbooks doctors pamphlets on
anything having to do with reproductive
health
guess who that affected oscar wilde and
even the canterbury tales were deemed
too sexy to send through the mail a
bunch of come stalkery
i say and also many others i sadly did
not coin that
term amy werbel professor of the history
of
art at the fashion institute of
technology
put it aptly comstock most typically
engaged in direct censorship when he
seized and destroyed materials to
prevent their public circulation
direct censorship in any society no
matter how repressive is just
one means through which discourse is
limited concern about the possibility of
censorship in many
cases results in an unwillingness of
artists and writers to risk producing
potentially indictable work resulting in
self-censorship
as individuals respond to perceived
limits in this manner
a new canon is formed shaping the
perception of what speech
is considered to be normal or
transgressive
this process of social censorship
typically serves to amplify the voices
of those who already hold power
and to reduce marginalize and silence
the expressions of those who are
vulnerable two legal cases that really
helped move the conversation in a
different direction were
the united states versus one book called
ulysses
in 1933 and rv penguin books
in 1960. the united states versus one
book called ulysses
centered around irish author james
joyce's ulysses
a book that i absolutely have read and
completely
respect the court argued that the book
was obscene and random house
argued that the content was protected by
the first amendment
judge john m woolsey stated that the
novel was serious
and that joyce was sincere and honest in
using a stream of consciousness to
explore the mentality
of its characters subsequently the book
was
finally allowed to enter the united
states
in rv penguin books the book in question
was d.h lawrence's lady chatterley's
lover
which is a book about a noble woman who
has an affair
with her gardener landscaping can be hot
during the trial mervyn griffith jones
the prosecutor
asked the jury to decide if the book was
obscene and if it had enough
literary merits would you approve of
your young
sons young daughters because girls can
read as well as boys
reading this book is it a book you would
have
lying around your own house is it a book
that you would
even wish your wife or your
servants to read wives and
servants reading about pleasure
i gasp gasps
aldis huxley in a handwritten deposition
to the defense team lady charlie's lover
is an essentially
wholesome book that a beautiful and
serious work of art should run the risk
of being
banned because its creator chose to make
use of
certain words that it is conventional to
regard it as
shocking this is surely the height of
absurdity
it seemed like the jury ultimately
agreed with huxley
and they voted that the book was not
obscene
in 1973 with miller v california
the u.s supreme court finally tweet
its definition of obscenity it went from
that of
utterly without social redeeming value
to that which lacks
serious literary artistic political
or scientific value big difference
huge today lgbtq books and books written
by authors of color depicting the
complexities of their lives
are still often challenged banned books
week was started in 1982
in response to the sudden surge in the
number of challenges
to books in schools bookstores and
libraries additionally every year the
american library association
puts out their list of the top 10 most
challenged books
in 2019 eight out of the ten had to do
with lgbtq
content as judith crune one of the
founders of banned books week put it
librarians are trained as librarians
we have absolutely no training or
expertise
in being censors our job and yours is
not to limit the horizons of a child
fee he's six or 12 10 or 20. our jobs
are to provide
all the ammunition we possibly can to
enable a child to expand
his horizons the right of any individual
to read
is an absolute necessity in a democratic
society
book banning is not about morality it is
about control
controlling the scope of the imagination
and smothering it before it can truly
grow
it is fine to expose children to
complicated books
but doing so asks us to talk to children
not just lecture them which people find
difficult
if we start policing the quality of a
book based on subjective
moral ideologies we're not doing
anything
we should be conscious of the kind of
work we expose children to
obviously but banning books because they
include
lgbtq families or because they talk
candidly about the realities of
marginalized existence
ignores that there are children growing
up in those families
and those existences that need these
books
quoting from krug again intellectual
freedom is the right of
any person to believe what he wants on
any subject
and to express his beliefs orally or
graphically
publicly or privately as he deems
appropriate
the ability to express one's opinions
however
does not really mean very much if there
is not someone to hear
what he is saying to read what he is
writing or to view what he is producing
through other methods
and so the definition of intellectual
freedom
has a second integral part and that is
total
and complete freedom of access to all
information and
ideas regardless of the medium of
communication
used information and ideas in turn give
a man
something to think about to consider to
weigh prior to coming to his own opinion
and decisions once these opinions and
decisions are formed and sometimes
before
he too is free to express his beliefs
and so
we have a circle and the circle breaks
however if either the ability to produce
or access the productions is stifled
so in life we have a choice do we want
to be
team comstock or do we want to be team
wild
choose wisely hey guys so before you go
pbs digital studios and it's lit want to
hear
from you it is that time of the year
again and we have our annual survey at
the link in the description
you can head down there and even
potentially vote on new shows that might
be produced by pbs digital studios
so yeet on down to that link and let
us and by us i mean them know
that it's lit is your favorite pbs show
because obviously it is
i have my band hammer um
i'll be like the band hammer